il serait temps d'en prendre conscience
et de commencer à s'y préparer dans un
an jour pour jour le franc a disparu de
la circulation il faudra bien se mettre
à l'euro reste que le temps d'adaptation
pour les particuliers n'est rien par
rapport au dispositif que les
entreprises les commerçants vont devoir
mettre en place bien avant il faut se
lancer vite disait laurent fabius ce
matin david boeri guillou [ __ ] à
l'euro ici on ne connaît pas pas encore
la préparation n'a pas commencé le
passage à la future monnaie c'est dans
moins d'un an autant dire que ce n'est
pas pour demain sur les étiquettes un
seul prix affichés en francs et ce
commerçant pour l'instant ne vois aucune
raison de se presser
on attend vraiment le dernier moment
c'est ce qu'il ya de puissance je pense
qu'il faut agir de façon instinctive
puis ça se fera tout seul d'autres ont
pris de l'avancé dans leurs préparatifs
mais ils ont encore beaucoup de mal à
sensibiliser leurs clients on a beau
avoir au niveau du ticket de l'eau
montant qui apparaît en euros mais les
gens ne s'en soucie pas encore dans son
propre sont pas vraiment confrontés au
problème
difficile de se mobiliser les pièces et
billets ne seront dans les porte-monnaie
qu'à partir de janvier proches pourtant
il est déjà possible de payer en euros
par chèque ou carte bancaire
voilà donc un problème nous avons pris
nos deux randonnées dire en fait déjà
commencé à être payés en euros il ya
passé
ensemble pour le gouvernement le pari
n'est pas encore gagné la préparation
des petites et moyennes entreprises est
en train de prendre du retard nous avons
encore beaucoup d'entreprises qui sont
qui n'ont pas commencé leur préparation
à l'euro + 40 % c'est quand même
beaucoup et donc il faut passer la
vitesse supérieure dès lundi prochain
une nouvelle campagne tentera de
convaincre entreprises et commerçants de
se préparer dès maintenant passer à
leurs opposants certain nombre de
problèmes et nécessite du temps
double affichage
évolution de sa paye
évolution de prise en compte de ses
relations avec ses clients avec ses
fournisseurs voilà donc aucun de ces
problèmes pris individuellement des très
compliqué mais mais l'addition fait qu'
il faut un peu de temps pour résoudre
toutes les questions autant de questions
qu'il faudrait régler d'ici l'automne
bien avant l'arrivée le 1er janvier 2002
des billets des pièces en euros